think about how many conclusions people
have come to throughout history that
have eventually been proven false
despite a majority of society agreeing
with the conclusions at the time they
were made this brings us to our next
fallacy appeal to the people or as it's
also known in Latin argumentum ad
populum this is an argument that
concludes that something is true or
false because many are most people
believe that the conclusion is true or
false this fallacy is also known as the
bandwagon fallacy an appeal to the
masses or the consensus fallacy do we
know that Christianity is true because
it has more adherents in the world than
any other religion do we know that a
political candidate was the best choice
in an election because they won the
popular vote do we know that a musician
has talent because their album sales are
through the roof the premise is most of
society believes X conclusion X is true
if this is meant to be a deductive
argument this argument is invalid
because the premise is irrelevant to the
conclusion something can be true even if
many or most people believe it to be
false and vice versa
the same thing would apply to a
deductive argument like this one most
people do X therefore X is the best way
to achieve Y as a deductive argument the
conclusion does not follow but an appeal
to the people can sometimes be valid in
an inductive argument for example if a
poll with a large population size is
taken in a certain city and the poll
finds that ninety-nine point seven
percent of people want their City
Council to take a certain measure on a
certain issue you could use that
premises and evidence to inductively
argue that the next person from that
area to be asked the same question will
probably side with the majority here
what most people believe actually does
have bearing on the trueness of the
conclusion but for instance it would be
fallacious to use that as proof
deductively that
what those 99.7% of people want their
City Council to do is the right thing to
do or that it will accomplish what
they're aiming for there are multiple
approaches to appealing to the people
the bandwagon approach hey everyone is
doing it and what is sometimes called
the snob approach hey all the best
people are doing it and the patriotic or
tribalistic approach everyone is doing
it who is a part of the group that you
are a part of or should be a part of or
want to be a part of the appeal to the
people fallacy is used all the time in
advertising
another example employees of
corporations often try to absolve
themselves in criminal proceedings by
saying everyone in our industry does
this it should be obvious that not every
idea or practice or opinion has merit by
mere virtue of its popularity but the
appeal to the people fallacy is an
important one to recognize because of
how often and carelessly it's committed
the critical thinking miniseries is made
possible in part by hover probably the
most important part of your brand's
identity online is your website and of
course the most important part of your
website is your domain name one of the
most common mistakes people make when
creating a website is buying their
domain name from the same people who
host their website your domain and your
hosting can be best kept separate for a
number of reasons if you change your
host you can keep your domain if your
site gets hacked you'll still have
access to your domain dashboard the best
domain registrar's are not always the
best at managing your website the list
goes on the point is you really are
limiting yourself if you buy your domain
from your website host and this is where
hover comes in hover is a domain
registrar with affordable prices and
hundreds of domain extensions you can
connect a domain name to any host or
website builder with just a few simple
clicks and there are no upsells
hovers clean and easy-to-use interface
is second to none and their
best-in-class customer service is always
there to help go to hover.com
slash Pakman for 10% off your first
order at checkout use the promo code
Pakman that's PA que ma n